this man is mighty with a book and a
sword
[Applause]
welcome to Jack being Colin O'Donoghue
this beautiful woman and body
seagulls oh well but in real life an
artist so so please please welcome Zanna
ha ha
[Music]
and no one at the way with magic like
this mystery man welcome Robert
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to have some others coming
out later but we wanted to give you guys
two violins with the people that we've
known and loved on the beginning I want
to start with a demented what are you
doing what's happening is one of us
elephant oh no what we're getting more
intimate hey wait no no no women what
this is not gonna be it stuff like that
we are here to celebrate a show that we
love we are one time and loving quality
I will shut this whole thing down you
hear me
so gather yourself oh my god what what I
was doing is we have planned tour the
original show the ran six seasons and a
point you felt like it was time for
characters to get the happening and what
we're going to do now is go on a new
adventure and so if your real fear is oh
my god are you going to erase the last
six years we are not but we are going to
take a few new characters so we're going
to go on a new journey and we hope you
come with us on
I want to say this too what is great
about this show up doesn't end like
three or four years now and every time
oh you guys do something that we're not
happy about we know where once if you
have someone don't light but usually add
vanity to start the questions are
answered
people are brought back things happen so
we want to take our time and just give
this creep of the what it deserves
okay just last season you got the other
food yes love him honor
Regina and the Evil Queen and see
together
yes you were brilliant and that evolved
what was keeping that life for you in
the ministry she had a message
flipping through the cadence of one when
we were doing the other and all that you
know I think you know costume help some
others that yes he's been separated but
it was awesome it was a great learning
experience it was challenging on many
levels I've never done anything like
that before I have a loss on doing and I
think you know these it's one woman
whose business who lit herself you know
this darkness and the light
part of her and I mean I just I think
that it was a sort of set a storyline a
lot of people can relate to you because
we all know that this darkness within us
and they'll kind of either really love
it and appreciated or really hated and
try to disrupt it right and it was it
was really great too
to see Regina finally get to this place
where she accepts her darkness and
embraces herself and and accept who she
is
so it was I like episode 14 one of my
favorite episodes for Virgina and I'm
glad we told that story and I had a fun
time doing it okay I don't think anyone
understands how hard she has work to do
television was cuz everything had to be
shot twice and had to keep track of and
it was a three-hour chain from Regina
end of the Queen not reality to do
putting on Weatherly we almost killed
her so you can give it up a lot of seven
days a week left one of the great things
about the show I think one of the
reasons we all love it is what Lana just
touched on there is good and evil in
each of us and I think Robert hi Jaime I
think you would body miss really well
because what I love about your art this
year and every year is we got to see you
fighting for both with everything you
have what is that light a fuse an
actress against a bright heart and
you're the crap out of people anything
what is it was that it's what I do
while an assessment of inspiration out
of an any interested the key very softly
and you take you know both end of the
spectrum gold you needed equal parts
kind equal parts not people and of
course an iconic Commission's Authority
she interested us for sure hopefully
keep the audience interested also do you
think if he had been yes approaches do
you think if he has been allowed failure
that he would still have that same push
and pull of maybe this is a question for
a penny as well I mean I don't know I
mean I was going to get too close to his
accounting analysis again I personally
think that is they cannot business level
both evil it's really the hardest in the
gun and I really don't like the Raghava
Holcomb to be a Deaconess area really
personally I think I think that the
complexity and I think that he plays so
beautifully is that every day he is
fighting between a good and evil and I
think whether he was you know I think
the penalty was almost
we're on and that's what it was and he
was always meant to do that
and he would have got there the same way
even if his mom didn't do what she did
but I'm glad that she did because I who
doesn't like seeing almost Duncan who
doesn't like people helping me
hey guys dreamy I love
we've seen a flashback to some of the
things that went on in describing the
family members what is something that
you wish you do or completion abandon
you about looking at past what make
Emily is I would like to know more about
house mother use what the way up sort of
touch done
yes that about how but I mean it's been
going to being able to salute you know
with with both Liam's bring them Alex
for their relationships which I think
you know is really important um you know
with hope who knows what we'll see next
season first together- named Morris 20
wins
but yeah it's been it's been fun you
know who gives a complicated time
character we break the excavation ships
in the past and the ones come yeah these
are your business of cast member that
the panel this year some people have on
physical engines new devices want to see
the buyers you want to say about these
wonderful people and maybe won't be bad
don't think just because they're not
here that they're not going to be
visiting either but I wanted to give you
guys a chance to you know hey I'm
actually wonderful people you know after
six years we just the best cast in
television I think we're gonna be truly
incredible people on the show and as the
show of all so we're telling some of
these new stories new chapters in to say
goodbye and none of that you know was
easy for anyone but you know it's our
hope that we'll be seeing a lot of them
from time to time throughout the season
this is the end and we're not erasing
anything like we miss them as much as
you do and you guys need to realize the
power of a guest star and a recurring
y'all those kind of people are referring
to help even though they have series
record is recurrent people can pop up
all the time you don't know okay well
speaking of the past and now the future
we have some new people we'd like to
introduce you guys do you want me from
the cracker first most recently solver
and Rose nyl devious maids but you mean
they were from xmen let's dance
Vampire Slayer hero welcome our new
Cinderella Daniel
have a lovely relationship with it on
television not in real life
in television you know over there in the
fans Walking Dead fans know him as eros
dead eight people y'all but he's like to
redeem himself as our beloved Hindery
Mills all gonna be welcome
these people they said was so involved
insurance a t-shirt and lastly I've been
a fan of influences in some woman you've
seen emotionally on Burn Notice
she's our new wicked stepmother Lady
Tremaine he's welcome get real
I have a question for the boys yeah
where did Henry get the gas for the
motorcycle bro I don't that we're here
for you to poke at plot holes if there
is a being that can transport him to a
new book don't worry about fuel I just
got myself fired all right to be honest
there is an X on between Agrabah and
Neverland they take a credit card or
fairy dust and so that will be episode
five thanks to Collin I land without
Chevron a land without Chevron okay you
guys
welcome new cast members thank you this
is a question for all three of you how
did you each come to be a part of once
upon a time what's your story how'd you
get here it's a fairy tale for me yeah
you know it's interesting because I
didn't know I was auditioning for
Cinderella so I was on a family vacation
actually in Hawaii with my kids and we
got a call that morning they said can
you get on a plane at one o'clock and
you know we want to test you for this
role in Once Upon a Time which I love
and I was super excited I got on a plane
came in to the room literally with
vacation clothes on little I mean I had
no idea what I was auditioning for just
walked in and they said we just want to
see if you have chemistry
well no either it's true with Andrew
who's playing older Henry and I was like
right oh whatever this is go in and do
this and and we just went in and had a
lot of fun and then got back on a plane
to Hawaii the next morning and when I
landed I got a call saying you got cast
and we're Cinderella and I'm oh my god
yeah that's very clearly like that isn't
really exciting and Andrew I want your
story first I want to say you have a
very talented wife yeah amber Stevens
West if you guys watched where my show
she here
amber she's amazing very talented I just
want to give a shout out to her how did
you become a part of the show in truth
yeah so I was lucky enough to work on
another show that Eddie and Adam were
were responsible for called dead of
summer platform I'm any dead of summer
fans that was so we don't be afraid to
look at it and re-watch it oh yes don't
be afraid he said all right so that was
last summer I worked on that I think I
did six episodes and I played a
character who is exactly like Henry I
mean you know long hair bandana 80s
metal head it made perfect sense that
you guys would but no so I worked on
that show and then you know that's how I
that's how I was introduced to them and
then I got the call that they were you
know maybe interested in having me come
in to do this so it was the same thing
you know we met we talked I did did a
reading and and that was it but I still
am wondering what what about the long
hair and the bandanna and the beard made
you guys think like yeah that's Henry no
it was the Satanism there was a I would
say the immense talent and I mean does
he not look like Jared grown up yeah how
dare you all grown up I'm going to go to
Gabrielle in a second but I wanted to
tell you guys I forgot to say this we're
going to get fan questions throughout so
carefully safety first if you have a
question get in line at the mics now
because I might be throwing to you at
any time and I'm going to bring
something up from under here but I'm
gonna wow that didn't sound right try to
move to Friday oh it sounded really did
it sound good Collin I'm going to we do
this guys we do this um uh Gabrielle can
you tell us your story about how you
became a part of this wonderful show
well it happened very quickly you know
one that I was also on vacation and I
got a call from my agent and I was with
my kids and it was loud and I said once
upon a time and my 13 year old daughter
went plop
haha and I'm like I can't him and I'm
like as I'm trying to listen to my agent
talking about this potential role my 13r
was grabbing me and she's going [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so I she's almost in tears and so I and
she's like so I said yes I didn't know
what I was saying yes to but I owed it
to my 13 year old who recently played
Tinkerbell in her school players who
should know better
oh wait though Here I am
that is so you know at my stepson who's
15 played Captain Hook in order to play
this energy it's synergy up here